now after watching all of this tonight i
have to conclude
today was a bad day for the democrats
why well they saw new polls showing that
the race is tightening
in the battleground stage which means
that they haven't gotten any real bounce
from their convention
they finally started to realize that
riots and looting
well that's hurting them politically so
they were forced to roll out old joe
with a statement
condemning exactly the type of violence
that has been roiling blue cities for
months
now tonight the republicans had more bad
news for the democrats
over and over republican speakers hit
themes and issues
that were simply ignored altogether at
last week's dnc
had a chinese activist warned about the
dangers of the ccp
a millennial candidate for congress
talked about how the gop is the party of
economic opportunities only 25 years old
and for the third night in a row a
lineup of
eloquent african-american speakers
rebutted the lie
that america is a racist country and
emphasized the long history of
republican support for civil rights
so in short it was another night of
positive upbeat messages about the
promise
of america